[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
uh
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
uh
[Music]
oh
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
[Applause]
she
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
so
come up do
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to gamespot's
pre-show for ubisoft's
september forward event uh i'm lucy
james joined by tomorrow hussein
hi uh and jordan remay
yo all right lads so we kind of know
roughly what to expect uh from today's
event
uh ubisoft has said there will be
hyperscape updates as well as watchdogs
legion uh given that we're
edging ever closer to the release of the
latter game i imagine we'll see
quite a chunky amount of the game before
we get into the games though obviously
we're gonna have to address
um ubisoft's statement that they finally
made
today um if you're unaware
i don't think they're actually putting
it as part of the forward event uh they
put it up on their social but they have
assured people that
it will be available on the vod versions
it just won't be on the live show
so uh ceo eve gilmour has made a
statement
about all of the allegations and
everything that's been happening at
ubisoft
over the last three months and well the
allegations that have come out over the
last three months it seems that it's a
problem that's been going on there
for years uh judging by all the accounts
that have been coming out
um it's um
a bit of a tricky one so we're gonna try
and do it
you know justice and talk about it
because it is something that needs to be
talked about ubisoft has had
one hell of a summer uh ranging from
sexual assault allegations
uh abuses of power to now the black
lives matter
um you know releasing a game that has a
logo in it that
is kind of equating the black lives
matter movement to uh
to terrorism and it's been
long overdue this apology um
and they've been saying that you know
they kind of put in place the
the measures that they're going to be
taking um
tam i'll come to you first what did you
make of eve's uh video
yeah i think the the first thing to say
is it is out there
um and people are saying is you know
good that he's done that but it is
also long overdue so let's not forget
that this should have been done way
earlier
um if only to give the confidence to the
people who work at ubisoft that their
leader is aware and and is addressing
the issue
so there is always going to be an
element of little late
but the fact that it has happened is um
valuable um hopefully it gives some
uh confidence to the people who work at
ubersoft that maybe something would be
done
um it would have been good earlier but
it's there the other thing that needs to
be addressed
is still how much involvement or
knowledge
eve had himself that's going to be a
tricky one to do
publicly maybe it's something that
happens you know behind the scenes but
the hope is that people who are in a
position to make ask those questions
are able to ask those questions without
persecution
and if they are persecuted or like crack
down in any way that there are avenues
available to them to make that
you know meaningfully uh apparent so
that it can be addressed
you know the the black lives matter um
kind of iconography used in the mobile
game
um which uh unwittingly according to
them
has equated you know the the movement to
a terrorist cell within their game
that's something that was overseen by
ubisoft's uh uh
ceo yves kimono son so there's an
element of
how how far does this run
the best we can do is take them for
their word right now
but i think it's important for everyone
to not let up on the scrutiny that the
company is being faced um the moment
people forget is the moment
a corporation will sweep it under the
rug and try and move on
so as people as gamers as people who
care about their games being made and
the people making them
we should be extra vigilant and extra
aware that the things that ubisoft and
eaves is saying and that is something
that they continue to do and are held
accountable for
that doesn't mean harassing people who
work there or harassing
people who you know are in public
positions at that company it means
maintaining a key awareness of what's
happening
in that company so that you can hold
people accountable in a small
and productive way too
absolutely and i mean it's
a very difficult one i mean even from
the outside looking in
but i'm not saying that all of the
problems there have been solved but it
is
uh you know it's good to see them say
that they're investing money
i feel like a million dollars over five
years i've given how much
the games bring in i feel like you could
maybe stretch that out a little bit more
but also it'd be a remiss of us not to
bring this up before we talk about the
games because ultimately
thousands of people work on these games
we said it before the last ubisoft
and
for this to overcloud everything is
you know and undermining all of their
work is just not right and we want to be
there we want to celebrate the games but
yeah we have to keep these people who
have been abusing their power
accountable so before i move on i'll
throw to you jordan if you've got any
last comments um
on the apology that you've issued today
i must say i
don't have too much to add it's one of
those kind of
better late than never type of
situations i would have enjoyed it if
something like this would have come out
a lot
sooner and been attached maybe to the
actual stream as opposed to just
released on those social
media channels but uh it's it's one of
those things tam did a very good job of
talking about it so i don't want to just
reiterate all the same points that
he just said it's one of those things
that i've been
frustrated about and i'm happy to see
ubisoft putting out
the statement but i now kind of just
i'm waiting to see what they plan on
doing from here
now that that statement is actually
finally here
absolutely and you know i assume
there'll be more ubisoft forwards and i
hope they
kind of realize the platform they have
with these forwards and they're not just
going to put things
on social like they are going to keep
people updated but we'll have to wait
and see
um and with that's going to be as
graceful as segway
i think as i'll come up with this
morning um
let's talk about the games themselves
uh yeah it's like i said there's no real
graceful way to segue there so the show
today we know there is going to be
watchdogs legion and hype escape those
are the games that have been uh
kind of in the blurbs of all of the
forward marketing
uh but we also know there is going to be
immortals
phoenix rising they did confirm the name
change from gods and
monsters um
i thought the monsters were very sweet
um but i'm also interested to see
like how that game has changed uh
tam is this one that's piqued your
interest
yeah i i you know i i'm interested in it
i think there's
a there is a a reasoning behind
that name change that i could cobble
together gods and monsters being a
very not not very seo friendly term
or title and if
remedy can release a game literally
called
control okay yeah
i must have had to seo
but i'll put the game like controllers
yeah go for it go for it i'm gonna say
the game the game itself like i'm i am
keen
to check out just because you know it
comes from the assassin's creed team
and we say team but like if it is indeed
that team
it's got to be a slice or a small group
within that team
and maybe i'm it's wishful thinking but
i'm excited about the idea of a smaller
focused
uh group of people within a team that
has already given us some
solid assassin's creed experiences uh
kind of focusing it down it's got a
legend of zelda kind of vibe to it that
i'm
interested in and like greek mythology
and mythology
being spun in new ways is something that
i'm always down for like
they do a lot in assassins they do it a
lot in various other you know god of war
did it um
so i i am excited to see where it goes i
think the name
is a bit clunky but uh i'm sure we'll
get over it eventually
yeah i mean i'm just excited to see more
of it it looks very very cute
um so we know that is a confirmed game
uh today
another one is going to be watchdogs
legion
one for the the brits to shine i was
watching the footage that they've been
releasing uh again yesterday to kind of
re-familiarize myself with it and
honestly watchdogs one didn't do it for
me
watch dogs 2 i liked a bit more but
three is the one where i finally feel
like this is where i'm gonna be
i'm gonna be in like even though i live
in san francisco now which shocks you
didn't do for me but watch three
uh watch legion i should say like just
looking and being able to immediately
recognize the areas that all these
characters are in
my one fear is that there might be i
might be paralyzed by choice
because there are so many to kind of
like
i don't know i'm probably just going to
pick the guy who's like john wick and
just do everything that way but
jordan uh are you excited for watching
watch dogs legion
i must say i i worry to say this i'm
like as someone who
does live in the san francisco bay area
i'm not sure if you should count on the
setting being familiar being your
parameter for
enjoying the game i wasn't the hugest
fans of watch dogs or
watch dogs 2. admittedly i played watch
dogs 2 i think
3-ish years after it come out so like
the open
world adventure game had kind of
expanded since then and the
mechanics of washouts 2 were kind of old
school
at that point so i'm excited i think to
see
how they can bring watchdogs into a more
modern day genre setting it's been one
of those things we've had
witcher 3 we've had breath of the wild
we've had a bunch of
open world rpg like actiony games that
have kind of expanded what you can do
in an open world and shown how you can
explore it and interact with it in brand
new ways and had these really awesome
side quests and npc story storylines and
i want to see that
in watchdogs legion and we haven't gone
too much into that most of the stuff
that they've shown is kind of just
showcasing the fact that you can play as
anyone which is still
very impressive and i can't wait to try
to
see how far that goes and recruit every
single person that i possibly can to see
if there's ever like a repeat and
storyline but it's
uh it's one of those things i'm kind of
like on the fence about just kind of
looking at it
from afar being like maybe i'll like
this maybe
but i'm i'm not convinced about it yet
that's fair i mean i think the thing i'm
excited about is um
i think there's a lot of really cool
like
slices of life of london that you can
see because london is such
a you can tell i'm feeling a bit
homesick but like london is such a great
city
because it has so many different
communities and such
like each district feels uh like a
different vibe
like each area of london um you know it
just feels like a completely different
place and i really hope that the team
have managed to
capture what makes london feel so london
it goes beyond
accents okay because some of these
accents are a bit
uh let's say dick van dyken
um but i'm really excited like
right now the the stuff i'm looking at
you can see the shot in the back uh
you know it's i'm very excited i'm gonna
go and try and find the old game spot
office
um but i think as well ubisoft never
really wants to get into politics
and i've told this story before but when
i interviewed someone from the watchdogs
legion team when they announced the game
a couple years ago it was like don't
talk about brexit
but i feel like you can't make a post
brexit game
and not make some kind of statement on
it
uh so i'm very intrigued yeah it's
hopefully it's gonna try and hopefully
something but i'm not putting too much
stock in it
tam uh before we move on uh watch dogs
are you in
yeah i mean i it's a lot of what you're
saying
and some of the motivations are similar
feeling homesick love london as a city
and
feel like it's such a diverse
interesting
environment i'm giving the team the
benefit of the
doubt right now in terms of how they
recreate is there
ubisoft if there's one thing that they
can do it's it's they put
um a level of detail into recreating
cities and golfer ambience and that kind
of stuff and
you know they did victorian london
pretty well so let's hope they do
uh modern london well um so
uh yeah i i am interested in seeing like
what jordan said how they bring this
into the modern day you know that the
systems that are at place
definitely seem ambitious and whether it
all coalesces without completely falling
apart and coalesces in an interesting
way
is the big question for me you know
we've got clint hawking
at the uh the kind of wheel a part of
this and he has created some of the most
interesting
ubisoft uh games specifically far cry 2
in the past
so i am i'm intrigued to see how that
team
puts uh you know all that stuff into a
blender and makes it and
what it comes out i feel like this could
be the start of like a new identity for
watch dogs
like jordan said it felt like a very
kind of vanilla open world experience
with some hacking elements here and
there up until this point
but it start to it started to get more
of a personality with two
and i feel like this could be an
opportunity for them to really solidify
mechanically what watchdogs is and how
it's different from these other open
world franchises
absolutely so i'm excited to see more of
it uh another title that we know is
going to be in the forward today is
hyperscape jordan i'm going to come to
you because you did review it for us
uh have you gone back to hyperscape
since you reviewed it
i i think i've played it
once since then but i'm
it's hard to keep up with multiple games
as a service titles and i already play
apex legend so i'm not like
jazzed about adding another battle
royale battle
pass to grind out and it's i don't know
there's something about hyperscape i've
gone over this a bunch of times in the
review already that just didn't
sit right with me so if anything i'm
kind of hoping that whatever they
show in the forward today addresses some
of the
things that i'm not a huge fan of with
close range weapons like the hex fire
just absolutely
demolishing people with some of the hack
special abilities
kind of seeming necessary and kind of
funneling people into specific builds i
would
love to see the game somehow some way
open it up to experience more freedom of
choice and how
you want to play the game and how you
want to fight because there's something
like
really cool there and how you can just
be this parkour superhero and get around
the map with
such relative ease if you actually know
where you're going because the entire
map looks exactly the same with muted
blues grays everywhere
but like other than that
i don't know i have no i have no idea
what they could possibly
show today i'm like what is it going to
be a new map
is it going to be new weapons like what
what's
what's going to what could they possibly
show that could like
bring me back into this game and i don't
think that there's anything
but we'll see let's see everyone have uh
yeah i mean the show's gonna start at 12
so uh we don't have that long to wait
we've got about 40 minutes
uh time i'm going to come to you with
this one because you
are our expert and maybe not expert but
you are the uh
the mouthpiece for when sam fisher is in
games that aren't splinter cell
so if he doesn't have a game
well i'm so glad that he just went live
in rainbow six siege uh
shortly before we started recording so
this update uh what was it called it's
called
uh operation shadow legacy uh it was
teased a while ago there's been a
trailer and some gameplay
i quietly went live uh this morning so i
assume it was supposed to be a
and you can play it today but it's
difficult to do that when you've got a
14 gigabyte update
and people turn on their ps4s and xbox
doesn't see it downloading so
like you're you're also a siege boy are
you gonna are you gonna main
oh he's not even called sam fisher in it
he's called uh
zero so they all have curses
yeah firstly i think it's i think it
says it all that they called a shadow
legacy which is like
this guy's legacy is just no one cares
it's just off off off camera
outside out of mind i think like as a
as a siege operator i'm intrigued to see
um how he fits in and see how
it changes the ma if at all as a as a
representation of sam fisher i think
it's pretty poor
like it's it's he doesn't function in
the way sam
fisher does like he's the most non-sam
fisher character
if you took the the kind of like i could
convince
very easily convince another player that
this guy has nothing to do with
clownfish
because he doesn't behave like sam
fisher at all like he's
none of his gadgets are kind of like
obviously sam fisher-esque
none of his movement he doesn't have
he's not like you know doing the splits
upper corridor like you know
from above or like hiding around corners
like he's got some basic
like tech stuff that could easily have
been
like given to any other no name
character
i might my hope again is like all this
non-stop sam fisher teasing is
for something that eventually shows up
um this is raising interest hopefully
but like
then again like this is not the most
interesting way to reintroduce sam
fisher to new audiences like he's
got an amazing legacy like this was
designed
you know splinter was designed as the
metal gear solid killer
which i don't think it did but like it's
got a long lineage and those games are
amazing and they're so cool and sam
fisher does have a story that you could
lean on
if if io interactive can make asian
agent 47 so interesting in this day and
age ubisoft should be able to make sam
fisher an interesting character and
present him back to the world in a
cool way this for me is not it um this
ain't the one
um i'm just holding out hope that you
know he eventually shows up in his own
game
um but as it stands zero interest in
playing zero if you know what i'm saying
very good i like the way that you kind
of came back around
uh to the title in there uh we've got
about 10 minutes and before we're going
to throw to ubisoft because they
have some uh some more reveals in their
pre-show so we're going to throw to them
at 11 30.
make sure to stick around after the
press conference press conference
digital event
uh we'll be here breaking down all the
new announcements so about 10 minutes to
go
what do you guys make of prince of
persia
so this is one that kind of like there
was a retailer leak a while ago and then
jason schreyer was on a podcast and he
was like
oh yeah there's a prince of persia a
remake coming
is the world ready for sands of time i i
assume it's gonna be times of time i
don't think anyone's clamoring for
warrior within but
i'm really like i remember loving that
game i absolutely adored it and then i
went back to trying like i was at my
mom's my ps2 was there i booted it up
and i was like
um assassin's creed has
uh trained me to create
a different level of hardcore in a game
um but honestly i would be well up for
revisiting that world jordan i'm gonna
come see you for this one
i say i'm the wrong person to ask about
this my entire
like well no my entire knowledge of
prince of persia is the fact that
oh prince of persia is where assassin's
creed comes from
i like assassin's creed and that's like
that's it for
me so if the if a remake does
come out then it'll be my introduction
to
prince of persia which i'm excited to
try for the first time
like it has a lot of fun mechanics like
using the dagger and like
parkour uh running over walls like just
holding i think it's r1 to run up the
wall but like
tam prince of persia your fan yeah
uh my name is persian so technically i
am the prince of persia so you know what
i'm saying
um i think uh i think
it's gonna be interesting to see
obviously there's been video leaks of it
now
um and and like cut scenes from it have
been shown
if they do a straight remake of prince
of persia i feel like it's kind of
pitching it at people who have nostalgia
for that game um
and you know or uh yeah it's people like
us but like even then like you said you
played it recently and if mechanically
it isn't
brought or cleaned up or smoothed out or
bought to some level of modern
kind of standards i wonder how much
mileage i will have for that like i
the nostalgia for me for prince of
persia isn't strong enough that
i will stick through a game that's
actively difficult or
not ideal or enjoyable to play because
of the dated mechanics
my hope is that along with the visual
overhaul which
we'll see how it looks but the the leaks
seem to indicate it's not like super
current journey it's like it's just
trying to be like a
a kind of small step forward but not um
kind of like
we've done the whole thing over again
that we'll see how that goes but like
more
more interested i mean is is like the
mechanical changes do they smooth it out
do they take some of what
ubisoft's assassins games have done with
parkour and kind of
um retrofit i would say not because
those those mechanics and that design
works in a very specific
open world framework um which this game
doesn't have but i would love for them
to
you know update it and make it feel a
bit smoother and maybe
you know smooth out some of the rough
edges that that game definitely had even
at launch
but still there's some magic there's
some magic in those sands of time
yeah they literally helped you rewind
you can tell that sometimes like tab
just comes up with a joke and then
like he just just works around he's
trying to build to it the entire
conversation
that is my entire memo
all right let's so we had an update on
skull and bones
jesus christ wasn't expecting to say
that because it's been like two years
since we actually heard about anything
to do with that game uh so i have a new
creative director elizabeth pellen who
is a director of 13.
she's been a ubisoft for a very long
time and uh the update was basically
we're still working on it but it
underwent a lot of changes
um jordan you and i have spoken about
skull bones a little bit before
what are you hoping to see in this one
i'm honestly not entirely sure i thought
it was a pretty interesting
premise to kind of go with it solely
sailing around being a
pirate type deal and now that they're
saying that they're kind of
going back to it and trying to rework
certain aspects of it i'm like
well they can't possibly be adding like
some
single player like on land option
because then they're just releasing
assassin's creed 4 black flag all over
again
and so i'm i'm curious to see
what they're actually planning on doing
to
change the game what are they actually
changing
is it like a very minor change what
we're going to see
a new trailer for i'm like oh it looks
exactly as it did back in
2017 or when we see it again is it going
to look like a completely
different game and it's just all up in
the air because
i mean the last time we saw it i wasn't
even working at gamespot yet
like it's been such a long time
it's it's very strange because it just
seemed i mean actually looking at the
footage now
this is just assassin's creed like i
swear that there is some
of the same animations just for boarding
the only thing they seem to have done is
change the font
uh so they've said it's not going to be
at the forward today i brought it up
just because it's
like bloody hell there's going to be a
um an actual update on it so
let's move on so i don't know if you
guys have been on twitter recently but
there's been a lot of talk about scott
pilgrim
uh brian lee o'malley who wrote the
comics has been saying yo ubisoft was
the game edgar wright who directed the
movie
has been saying where's the game it got
de-listed a while back
impossible to find it play it i think i
still have it on an old xbox 360 hard
drive
um but a fantastic fantastic uh
score as well by anna managucci is that
how you say
it yep all right however
do we think that the cries have been
heard and that they'll actually bring it
back
tam i mean
sure why not i feel like this is a
extreme case of people saying they want
a thing that no one
actually wants like you know why brian
lee o'malley wants it
because he makes money off of it that's
why brian lee o'malley wants it
and like sure it was a great it was a
great game back then but like
and it will be fun to check out these
days so i'm not opposed to it whether it
will happen
i'm not so sure like dude does ubisoft
want to spend the money to potentially
you know
re-up on that license agreement so that
they can
please a a small group of fans like
scott pilgrim is great like the the
movie is great
the comic is wildly problematic in by
modern standards but uh
um
yeah it's it's got some cool sequences
in it but
i would i would like to see it i don't
know if ubisoft cares enough
um and i think it's one of those things
where more people want it because
you know they have nostalgia for it then
then it all kind of like you know
actually the amount of people that will
play it and cough over the money for it
i'm not convinced it's like a
a crazy amount but like if they put it
out i would buy it because that game is
fantastic and it's and it's great in
like
co-op and multiplayer um and i like nice
shop
i never finished that game because it
was too
hard for me uh so maybe
it was it was fun but like it was super
hard
so maybe if they do replace it they'll
hopefully make it a bit easier
okay we've got like two minutes before
we're gonna throw over to ubisoft's uh
pre-show um are we expecting much from
assassins today
the uh release date has just been
brought forward to november 10th
to launch as a launch title for series s
and series
x jordan do you think we can get
anything today anything of
meaty probably not i
imagine if anything they're just gonna
show us gameplay of
female ivor since they've only been
doing
mail for the past few times and that'll
be like the big thing
but we'll see maybe they'll surprise us
with some brand new mechanic or mission
structure or something
it's very strange because like usually
in the run-up to an assassin's creed
game
uh they release approximately 30
trailers and i am i'm not
over exaggerating like if you go back
and see what they used to do
for syndicate um and unity if you go
to your soft official channel and look
at the playlist they have
so many trailers and so many like dev
updates and it feels like they're kind
of
holding back a little bit on this one
which i'm excited which mean because it
means like every time i get
a fresh look at the game i'm actually
not just like oh well they've shown that
before they showed that before it's like
it's ubisoft being a bit more measured
with assassin's creed which i appreciate
um
we're gonna throw in like maybe a minute
or so so final thoughts
uh what are your wild card predictions
for this forward tab
splinter cell finally sam fisher is back
he's uh been remade for the modern
generations
so the first i don't know trilogy of
games
are remade um that's my wild card
the hope and dream let him dream
uh jordan what about you uh rainbow six
quarantine gets announced with a brand
new name
and title oh my god i forgot about that
one i guess you can't
i think ubisoft wants you to forget
about it too
i feel like i can't really release the
game about quarantines uh in the middle
of a global pandemic
uh i think honestly you know my my wild
card
is the beyond good and evil might show
up
like that's a dream that is a dream
that's a dream
i don't know they had that big prb a
while ago with joseph gordon levitt and
hit record being involved and then
nothing for a couple years so
it's about time i still don't understand
what that game is but i would be
intrigued to see it or maybe oh a remake
of beyond good and evil i would really
really appreciate that
uh okay so we're gonna go first put sam
fisher in
in in beyonce
[Laughter]
probably but you know i'd play that
uh all right so we're going to head over
to the ubisoft free show then it's going
to be ubisoft forward september edition
uh make sure to stay tuned
right here we're gonna have our post
show talking about all the new
announcements
we'll catch you then directors often
featuring pixta cat
our mask for karma it all started in the
metro
in paris you know when you exit the
subway
there are these very heavy doors that
you have to push
hard to open often the one who opens one
of them waits a bit
and then holds the door open for the
person coming next
and this person in turn holds it open
for the next
and there are always smiles and thank
you exchange between
complete strangers we wanted our game to
feel
just like that karma is an online game
where you will play with a team of a
dozen of persons
picked up completely randomly all of
them collaborating
sharing lights and resources and
struggling together
to find the axes every player controls a
soul who can change into a fistful of
animals each of which having
special powers all of these powers have
to be
combined in the timely manner to
enlighten the path
that leads to the next level of the
sankhata
only helping others will allow you
to improve your karma and access new
creatures
and powers karma is still in development
but we really
really can't wait to share the light
with you online
in 2021
if you're just joining us you're
watching the official ubisoft forward
pre-show
coming up news on for honor the division
2 ghost recon break point
and more and there's something special
going on at the ubisoft store
you can get an extra 20 off with the
code ub forward
on store.ub.com the code works on
already discounted classics such as
assassin's creed odyssey
the division 2 or far cry 5. simply add
the code at the checkout and enjoy
hours of fun at ubisoft we always like a
bit of friendly competition
for the second year in a row ubisoft
organized an internal contest called
pets of ubisoft to find our team's most
adorable
animal companion let's take a look at
some of the cutest pets that were
submitted to the contest this year and
find out who was crown
winner of the pets of ubisoft 2020
over the years ubisoft's games have
featured some iconic animals
including loyal companions like the
fangs for hire in far cry
and the eagles in assassin's creed
assassin's creed valhalla will even let
you pick up cats and pet them
[Music]
but have you ever thought about the
real-life pets that inspired these
in-game animals
our teams can always count on the
support of their furry
scaly or feathered friends so we wanted
to take some time to celebrate these
loyal life companions
brave work from home buddies and cute
four-legged friends
or no-legged friends and also
shrimp ubisoft team members from around
the world
submitted pictures and videos of their
dogs
cats horses rabbits squirrels
a praying mantis and shrimp
for this year's edition of the pecks of
ubisoft contest
and now introducing the winner of pets
of ubisoft
2020 ragnar the guinea pig dressed up as
chorizo in his libertad outfit from the
upcoming
far cry 6. check out our life at ubisoft
accounts for updates about life in our
studios
and even more adorable pets
congratulations once again to this
year's winner ragnar the guinea pig
remember to check out the life at
ubisoft channels on social media
where we regularly share updates on
what's going on in our studios around
the world
up next let's see what's new with our
favorite racing game
the crew 2. the team at ubisoft ivory
tower in lyon
france has some exciting news in store
for us a whole new way of enjoying the
game
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone i'm sofian vaimi life
producer here at ubisoft ivory town
for two years now we've welcomed
millions of players and deployed major
updates
every four months these updates brought
a variety of new content to the game
with a particular focus on competition
but we will not stop here from november
everyone will discover new ways to enjoy
our game
a new season system will be introduced
each of these seasons will last
four months and will be split in two
different
episodes our objective here is to
continue to deploy new content
for all types of players to achieve this
we will introduce waterflex a new tv
show company
that will hire you for your driving
skills so
without further ado here is a glimpse of
what's coming in november 2020
hey we have a situation
[Music]
something some someone tricked the alarm
now
we've got a visual they're getting away
take them out
the package cannot leave the city
that's right the crew 2's new season
system kicks off this november with
season 1
episode 1 the chase now it's time to
check out the latest news from tom
clancy's ghost week on breakpoint
led by the team at cubist of paris they
have a brand new adventure in store 4
player this fall
in episode 3 red patriot so call your
friends or prepare your ai teammates
and get ready to dive back into aurora
hurry up
[Music]
is the leader of raven's rock codename
basilisk he's an ultra nationalist
turned rogue
with requisite hatred of the us son of
the lady
no sexual
the leader of raven's rock you might
have heard of it you are fast enough
you may be able to save innocence from a
horrible death
the timer has begun hurry save the
others
and try not to die
ready for uplink
you will remember your promise to us yes
first the united states
then we take back my country i'm a man
of my word tovarish
our plan will bring balance once again
i have one final request i wish to hunt
these ghosts who plague you
well if you so desire
then i'm happy to let you handle them
[Music]
this new adventure will be full of
twists and turns ghost recon breakpoints
episode 3 is the final update from the
season pass
red patriot alongside the new pathfinder
class and many more updates
will be out on september 15th at e3 last
year ubisoft montreal announced its new
free-to-play 3v3 competitive roller
skating game
roller champions let's see what the team
has been up to since then
[Music]
[Applause]
hello champions it's been way too long
hasn't it
but i think i know what you want to know
and heck i am happy to oblige
roller champions is coming early 2021
so much has happened and so much is yet
to happen
what better time for an update
roller has shifted from live phases to
workshopping with smaller groups of
players
and that has had a massively positive
impact on our development
but it also created a bunch of memorable
moments in the ring and you feel new
areas for the team to focus on
yeah the experience overall was just
great at the end of nights on certain
days we would get together
and put the top players against other
top players to kind of see what the
gameplay looks like at the highest level
i'd say
pretty much every session we had they
were
pretty much a new patch so we were
getting our feedback put into the game
pretty quickly it was really impressive
roller champions has very clear
competitive play ambitions but we also
want the game to appeal to as many
players as possible
that is why from our first workshop
we've been adding moves tweaking moves
and even tested game modes just so we
can find the best experience possible
and we've been way too discreet about
them thus far
[Music]
we're excited to announce that starting
october to the rolly champions blueprint
initiative
we're to give you a behind-the-scene
look at the development and upcoming
futures
we're talking video dev diaries and
commented development
our blueprints will delve into gameplay
art
lore and so much more blueprints are not
only about giving you visibility they
also mention you say discussion through
voting and activities
if you want to jump in with us then
follow us on social or join our discord
so we can make the best roller
experience possible
if you haven't played yet just be
patient it's coming soon
give the game at least an hour of your
time and you will fall in love with it
this game is superb it's a great concept
it's got so much potential as well this
game in this community has already done
so much for me
to the dev team from a regular guy who
just likes to play video games every day
thank you for making the game i never
knew i needed to play and now that i
have i don't plan to stop anytime soon
[Applause]
world champions is coming in early 2021.
in the meantime you can expect a lot
more news in the next few months and a
behind-the-scenes look at the
development of the game
with the upcoming blueprints dead
diaries follow the game on social media
and join the roller champion's discord
channel
to get the latest news and you can even
stick around for a closer look at some
roller champion's gameplay after the
main show
developing a video game requires a lot
of time and effort and part of that
process
is getting feedback from you real
players but in the current context it's
not always possible to get people to
come to our studio to test our games
that's why our user research teams have
been working on a new solution to allow
players to test
our games remotely let's learn more and
find out how you can participate
in this video
all right let's do this okay i'm not
gonna make as far as i thought
there's another team here
i got it we need the protector
oh crap i love it we got this we got
this
oh my god oh my god i'm running away
[Music]
good job guys
remote play tests are already open for
those of you located near ubisoft studio
but very soon you'll be able to
participate in play tests no matter
where you live
you can register to participate at
playtest.ubsoft.com
it's a unique experience and a unique
opportunity to help our development
teams make their games
even better for second in the highlight
let's meet spanish developer beautiful
glitch and discover the upcoming game
monster prom 2 monster it's just your
typical multiplayer monster dating sim
with
awesome art ballroomer and difficult
choices
hola i'm julian quijano from youtube
luggage we are in the studio based in
sunny barcelona
in spain two years ago we released more
surprise it's a multiplayer narrative
adventure
that mixes particular mechanics and
latency mechanics
it shines because of its irreverent also
humor and because of its colorful roster
of characters
basically plays like a dating him but up
to four people so you can have some good
laughs
and even fight for long now we're
working on the sequel
the name is monstercam this time instead
of looking for a day to prom you will be
having like lots of wacky misadventures
in summer camp and maybe you will even
find a summer love
there's a lot of monsters to romance
from above below the monasters who wants
to conquer summer
to an influencer who happens to be a
detroit party monstercam is an outget
though
but we prepare them you can download it
you can wishlist the game
and basically you can start exploring
how it goes and maybe finding your
monster match
because you know it's okay to fear
monsters but it's even more okay to fall
in love with them
right
[Music]
hey everyone we are back and you're
tuning into the pre-show for this
edition of ubisoft forward
we have a lot more planned to show you
about ubisoft our games
and our teams so stick around speaking
of our teams
one of the questions that we got asked
the most is how did you start to carry
in video games
what's your story laura well for me it
actually all started with a tweet
a developer working on siege tweeted
about a job opportunity and i just sent
my resume
and ubisoft took a chance on me mine is
a bit weirder
i was in a manga store and i was talking
with a guy that turns out to be working
for ubisoft i told him how passionate i
was
about assassin's creed first trailer and
a year later i was here in montreal
working on assassin's creed too so
everyone should take a chance now we've
asked the exact same questions to our
colleagues and we hope that their answer
would inspire all of you
let's take a look how did i get into
video games
funny story lucky coincidence it was
destiny
this is the most cliche story of all i
liked playing video games i got into
video games
i've worked in marketing for my entire
career but primarily in tech companies
even though i'm not a hardcore gamer
like some around here
six years old started programming six
years old played my first game
it was like this is what i'm going to do
even if i don't have a video game
experience
i could be interesting profile for the
company
i studied chinese language myself i'm
not a hardcore player but i
really like this environment that people
are pure
and creative so i did my masters in
creative writing
psychology mechanical engineering i have
studied 3d so i am actually a 3d texture
artist
who got into management after college i
had the opportunity to
grab an internship at ubisoft i stayed
as gameplay programmer afterwards i
ended up at ubisoft red links
through the ubisoft graduate program so
this is a two-year program that we have
within ubisoft for people who have just
graduated from university
i went to game design school because i
knew from the start that i wanted to
work with games
i started working in the industry as a
qa tester
i started in the late 19th as a
game tester i started as a tester
because i think all
all developers almost start as testers
is very common and then i was hired i
was a scripter at first then became a
level designer
mission designer and after that team
lead
assistant level design director and now
we're here
i got this opportunity through a friend
actually a good friend of mine joined
after some time he said man it's awesome
here
you should come i did something
completely different in the past i'm
actually
i learned and i did this for many years
uh endurance and finance advisor
so i did a job in a suit
right television
i used to work in medical imaging as a
project manager
and project management is what allowed
me to get my foot in the door here at
ubisoft i actually left
an iep company for a gaming company so
that's it
i loved gaming since the very start so
my background is actually in drinks
well i've always loved gaming and i've
always wanted to get into gaming but
there's just never been that opportunity
i was just lucky enough to apply for
this job at ubisoft and it all just
fell into place in a really good way
it's just been a year
and it's been hell of a diet i actually
have to decide like what you're going to
do now okay i want to do something
different this is not what one i want to
do this is
interesting but i would like to try
something else why not video games
you're young you can try it
what i have to lose and they said okay
you're hired
if you want to join and you think you
have the right skills
by all means join
if like the people in the video you're
interested in starting your own career
in video games
you can check out our current job
openings at jobs.ubisoft.com
next for honor developed by ubisoft
montreal
has had an amazing journey since the
game launched in 2017
and there's a lot more to come but for
now the team is excited to share a sneak
peek
of year 4 season 3.
maybe the war mongers were right
maybe we were foolish
to hope for more
maybe we deserve to be
punished
it would be easier to give up
and let them decide our fate
but we won't
[Applause]
[Music]
because it only takes a spark
to start
[Music]
a rebellion
we are happy to announce that 400 has
reached the 25 million player milestone
that's truly amazing
big thank you to the entire foreigner
community for those who want to learn
more about the next season that was
teased in this trailer
stay tuned for an upcoming foreign
warrior's den on their official twitch
channel
now for the latest on tom clan season
division 2 the team at ubisoft massive
in malmo sweden has an exciting new game
mode
called the summit let's see what it's
all about
[Music]
foreign
crazy
[Music]
shout it out
pictures
nothing can stop us
yeah we are the victors
[Music]
hello i'm yannick boshro here at massive
we are excited to bring you the summit
a new game mode that will have you
challenge your way up 100 floors
and where every attempt will be unique
it will come alongside season 3
concealed agenda as we continue the
story with the leader of the black tusk
barden schaefer
later this year we will be bringing you
season four that will see the return
of fei lao and a new time limited
in-game event that will be a truly
memorable experience and finally
i am thrilled to confirm that the
division 2 will be backwards compatible
with next gen consoles
more news on that mysterious in-game
event will be coming out later this year
and it will be available for players who
are making the switch to next gen
console
in the meantime you can try out the
division 2's new summit game mode
starting on september 22nd and if you
haven't played the division 2
the upcoming free weekend is a perfect
opportunity to give it a try
and now it's time to send it over to you
our players
our fans our communities let's see what
kind of cool stuff you've been up to in
our games
in the latest episode of wow moments
[Music]
bounce up
what what
thank
are you serious give me a green card
what are you doing holy [__]
[Music]
oh what i'm doing
[Applause]
oh hey check out the deagle oh
he's fine don't even just don't look at
him don't look at him he's fine
see he's not even there figment of your
[Music]
imagination
okay
that was so cool and thank you to
everyone who submitted some gameplay
if you have any clips you want to share
with us you can head over to
www.ubisoft.com you might even be
featured
in the next episode of wow moment that's
all for us the main event is about to
begin
thanks for watching the ubisoft forward
pre-show up next
the main show featuring new
announcements and a few surprises you
don't want to miss
[Music]
[Applause]
face is on gun's out it's about to get
real
[Music]
just
meet the see the devs
join us
welcome back to ubisoft forward i'm
yousef
i'm neela today's show will reveal new
games
give behind the scenes insights from our
development teams
and share some exciting updates on
projects you've been waiting for
let's get started with a game you've
been waiting to hear more about since it
was teased last year
the gods of ancient greece need a hero
and it's time to answer the call
as the world crumbles
our divine powers sealed away
even the gods need a hero
[Music]
hey
come on
[Music]
um
is
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is scott phillips and i'm the
game director on immortals phoenix
rising
i hope you enjoyed our reveal video i'm
sure you noticed a lot of new things
since we first
teased the game including a new name
extra production time has allowed us to
expand our vision and explore
new opportunities beyond our initial
plan we felt the name immortals phoenix
rising better reflected this new
experience
today we're incredibly excited to give
you the first in-depth look at our world
hero and gameplay let's dive in
immortals phoenix rising is a
third-person open-world action-adventure
game
set in the fantastical landscape of
greek mythology
you'll play as phoenix a greek warrior
shipwrecked on the mysterious golden
isle
upon your arrival you'll meet hermes one
of the few remaining gods of olympus
hermes has heard of a prophecy that only
you can save the greek gods
and reclaim their realm from typhon the
deadliest titan in mythology
[Music]
this entire epic story will be narrated
by the titan prometheus
and zeus the king of the gods adding a
unique commentary and perspective to
this legendary tale
[Music]
before embarking on this perilous
journey you'll get to create
your own phoenix
and as you progress you'll find even
more opportunities to customize your
character
by discovering legendary weapons unique
pieces of gear and cosmetics
and earning the god's blessings and
mythical abilities that can turn the
tide of battle
you'll need all the help you can get to
save the gods
and defeat typhon once and for all
on your journey to save the gods you'll
grow stronger and
achieve new incredible things like
gliding with the wings of daedalus
to jump higher fight while airborne and
glide freely
in the open world facing off against
dangerous mythical beasts
like the giant cyclops flying harpies
and
huge multi-armed hekatonkaries
harnessing the power of the gods to
master a tactical
and fast-paced over-the-top combat
system
and solving puzzles and challenges
scattered throughout the world
to help improve your powers
[Music]
you'll also get to explore an epic
vibrant and stylized open world
filled with secrets puzzles and stories
rooted in greek mythology
once a peaceful home to the gods of
olympus the golden isle is now
overrun by creatures of the underworld
to stand a chance against typhon and his
minions
you'll need to explore this mysterious
land and become a mythical hero
yourself
the world is divided in multiple regions
all ruled by a different god
in need of your help from the lush
landscapes of aphrodite's planes
to the mechanical world of festus's
forge
each region is packed with challenging
battles ancient puzzles
and secrets to uncover
you'll have the freedom to explore this
entire open world
as you wish right from the beginning of
your journey
[Music]
finally stay with us for the post show
where you'll get a look at new gameplay
i hope you enjoyed what you saw today we
can't wait for you to play immortals
phoenix rising
there's a lot more to show before launch
so keep an eye out for further updates
see you all on december 3rd i'm so
excited to play this game it's a world i
just can't wait to explore
hi i'm phil harrison we're looking
forward to immortals phoenix rising
coming to stadia on december 3rd
we're also excited to announce that all
stadia players
will get a chance to try immortals
phoenix rising
with a free playable demo before launch
that is exclusive to stadia
all you'll need is a gmail account with
just a single click
you'll be able to add the demo to your
stadia library and
instantly join phoenix on her quest to
save the greek gods
created specifically for this stadia
demo ubisoft have developed an entirely
unique island for you to experience
we hope you'll love it the exclusive
stadia demo of immortals phoenix rising
will be playable later this year in all
regions where stadia is accessible
thank you to eve guimo and the entire
ubisoft quebec studio for your
partnership
in bringing amazing experiences to
stadia
the use of zeus and prometheus as the
narrators in immortals phoenix rising
led to a unique style of storytelling
here's michelle plourde to tell us more
my name is michelle i'm lead cinematic
designer on immortals phoenix rising
i think the number one thing that i love
about my job is
the sense of pride that i get for
delivering a scene
our job is consistent with someone who
is actually directing
we get to direct where we're shooting
what lens we're using and what's
happening in the scene
immortals phoenix rising it's a very
narrative driven game
but it's also very light-hearted and
stylized and
very comedic and i feel like that's
where we get to shine as cinematic
designers
one of the best examples i have actually
for this is zeus and prometheus or
bickering
because zeus is very very much bored
about the prometheus story
so he decides to spawn some monsters and
then they just kind of appear
in the world and then the characters see
so we just kind of crash rooms
on them because we were trying to hit
comedic timing
so there's little moments the kind of
like light-heartedness and
part of the game that we we really like
to showcase
ubisoft really likes to tell stories
and i think that's how you get the
players to really be engrossed within
a world we want to make them feel
something
even if it's just a laugh or a chuckle i
think we did our job
keep an eye out for further updates on
immortals phoenix rising before it
launches
this december 3rd now it's time to
revisit
a dear friend
most people think time is like a river
that flows swift and sure in one
direction
but i have seen the face of time
and i can tell you
they are wrong
[Music]
inside the hourglass is a marvel no
living man has ever seen
only the dagger can unlock the sands of
time
i saw my father turn to sad
you cannot defeat this enemy the sands
will consume
everything come with me then but i warn
you i move pretty fast
you'd better keep up
the dagger it get turned back
give me the dagger never
[Music]
i brought this on us you are brave
my name is anukol i am working in an
ubisoft from past 13 years
anew is the senior producer of prince of
persia sands of time remake
for me it's a big dream it's not a
project it's a dream
that is coming true
[Music]
original prince of persia you know
people love this game
it has put a mark in everyone's heart
and now what we are going to do is we
are going to bring it back
because still people have that nostalgic
feeling people want to
play that game we are in an indian
studio it's a newbies of pune and bombay
we actually love to work on this game
because we can show
everyone you know what india is it's
something
which comes directly from our heart so
you know the main game which was
uh made back then the myth essence is
there all the characters are there you
have your prince
who's very iconic who was in this game
you have the princess
farah and later only you have a bazil
who is a main villain in this game with
all the sand creatures
you know it just we have give it a boat
bit more flavor-ness bit more
enhancement
the voice which we are using for the
prince is yuri the same
voice which was back then you know it
just put goosebumps on our hands also
when we
heard him because it's something which
which bring back to us to other than
that nostalgic feeling
how did some people say time is like a
river
that flows swift and sure in one
direction
17 years later but you know the main
good thing is his voice hasn't changed
at all
i don't know how he do it but it's the
same
being able to work under prince of
persia is a huge honor
because i think it's a beloved game
we respected the original design we
respected the storyline we respected the
characters
we just enhanced everything in the game
from camera
to combat as well as the visuals
[Music]
we implemented a targeted system which
actually enhanced the velocity of the
prince and his abilities to
do amazing performance and amazing moves
we use the latest technology as well as
the motion capture
to bring realism and to bring logic and
sense
into the story we heard the players
desire to play the prince of persia
sense of time again and we are very
pleased
to bring it as the first ever remake
from ubisoft
it's a beautiful story we are very very
excited to give you this experience
prince of persia stands the time remake
releases january 2021
on ps4 xbox one and pc
it's time to head over to the virtual
city of neo arcadia
where an intense and fast-paced battle
rages on
reload bunny
i've never felt like that in a vr game
before
but i think i like it
[Applause]
yep
oh
[Music]
that's us that's us
one big focus for the hyperscape dev
team is to regularly add
gameplay content and features keeping
the game new and fresh
week after week
this next one is for the fans
[Music]
it's a heartbeat a pulse a distant
vibration
it's a surge a rush
to rob a nation
it's nothing you could have predicted
but everything you believed in
it's nothing you expected
but everything you have achieved it's
nothing you could have trained for
yet everything you would have wanted
it's bigger than you could ever imagine
yet everything you always needed
it's everything you achieved everything
you cared about
it's everything you accomplished
everything you cheered for
it's in every strategy planned in every
inch you gained
it's more than gaming it's more than
just support
sitting in it's center here coastline
and open area
but they all know he gets taken down so
quick from the defense
through there they're both on the side
it's gonna run the corner finds one kill
the second one goes down
share every moment share every action
share every emotion share every struggle
share every success every triumph
yeah share it with your friend your
family
your teammates your people your country
share the unforgettable
i'm danielle is part director for
ubisoft today we are proud to have more
than 60 million player rainbow six siege
and we can say that we are top tier
sport title it was the right moment to
have
a new layer of competition we are
working on esports for the last five
years when we define a professional
system with organization and regional
model
so the rainbow six world cup is a new
layer of competition
of our esports ecosystem it will be the
first time we have a country based
competition
for our esport title in the rainbow six
world cup we'll have
20 teams participating to the main event
but more than
45 countries will participate to the
qualifier
for such a special occasion we are very
happy
to introduce tony parker our ambassador
for the rainbow six world cup
i'm very proud to be with tony parker
today
so you will be the ambassador of our
first rainbow six world cup that's what
i heard
yes that's the room in the streets so
you are part of
all the process of thinking about the
world cup you will meet
the players the coaches first of all i'm
very happy
very excited about the opportunity to be
an ambassador of the rainbow six for the
first rainbow six
world cup thanks for choosing me i'm
excited to meet all the players and
explain to them how special it is to
play for your country it's very
different than team playing you know
like when you go to your country and you
listen to the national anthem and
you have the goosebumps and then you
know it's a great honor these guys they
play for organizations that don't play
for their country yet
for them it would be something
completely different it will be the
first time they will not play with their
teammates
their player usually what would be your
advice
enjoy yourself because it's a unique
experience
to play in an international competition
and then there's all the pressure
around it you know because when you play
for your country a lot of pride comes in
and
and it's going to be a whole new uh
competition but i'm sure
uh if they can feel what i felt you know
they will love the the experience and
and i think in the global scale for
ubisoft and rainbow six to take that
challenge to do a
a world cup i think it can be big you
know for the future for the future of
the game
i think it's just a huge opportunity you
know and i'm very proud to be
part of it an ambassador like nba
champion tony parker just adds to the
excitement for this
massive event keep your eyes on all the
rainbow six siege social accounts for
more updates
we're not done just yet with rainbow a
new season is starting tonight
so let's see what the team has planned
hi i'm leroy creative director on
rainbow six siege
the rainbow six world cup is going to be
exciting and bringing the best player
from countries all over the world in
summer 2021
but for now let's focus on what is
happening in the game
right now a couple of years ago we made
the commitment to be live for at least
10 years
and today we are already close to the
half weapons of this symbolic milestone
we are not only maintaining this
commitment but we are doubling
down by investing more than ever to make
the game grow
and evolve this season will be siege
biggest one to date and we're excited to
bring a familiar face
to the rainbow six operator roster
permanently
sam fisher our callsign zero in siege is
bringing his combat experience and
training
into the game we are a huge fan of sam
and we wanted to show you how it fits
within our universe
check this out
lira how's that stuff work on arthritis
the nanobots should help but you'll pay
for it tomorrow
that sounds fair to me harry says you're
here to whip us into shape
that through let's find out
move out people
hmm
hmm orcs
oryx which are sid wrap dammit
how did the first lesson go you might
want to call a medic
r d has set up the facilities you
requested same time tomorrow
that's the deal splendid anything else i
can do for you sam
yeah call me zero
[Music]
the new season is live right now and
we're excited to get your feedback on
xero
and the rest of features coming out
before i go
we also wanted to share some more good
news for our players
as you know this year is special since
the ps5
and the xbox series x are coming out
today
we want to announce that we are going to
bring you the best cg experience on
console
in 2020 with up to 4k and 120 fps by the
end of the year
and best of all current console players
will all get this update for free
when they upgrade to the next gen
platform of the same family
as we said we are in this for the long
run and we have plans for years to come
thank you now it's time for a sneak peek
at another fan favorite making its
return
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
hey
it's time to check in on the dystopian
police state of future london
music is a huge cultural touchstone and
when you're working on a game that's
set in a real place it's something that
you have to focus really hard on to make
sure you get it right
when we asked londoners who was an
artist
who would really reflect and and
underscore the themes of watchdogs
legion
uh you know speaking up for the
oppressed and holding those in power
accountable there was
one name that came up over and over
again
this guy went from you know freestyling
in the london underground music scene to
headlining at glastonbury in less than
five years he's had
massive critical and commercial success
he's been on the cover of time magazine
he's won
dozens of awards um and he really has
used his voice
to speak up and fight for social and
political change
here and i am proud of wanting to
announce that i am a part of watchdog's
legion you don't
have to have all mines belong what they
have done in terms of recreating london
is the most insane
epic incredible thing i've ever seen
so i wanted to be a part of it you guys
are about to get an exclusive
sneak peek of some behind the scenes
footage and also
of my brand new music video rainfall
which is going to be a part of the games
me and manager got a wicked relationship
with the excitement he phoned me with
i hadn't heard since i got booked for
glass though cause i was like yo
bro there's this game i'm getting bored
you boys flex when i'm looking like the
older my boys
big mac i was making all of the noise
and the big bird jacket
they raped me that's so blatant when i
saw the future i'm that's so raven
whenever they say my name i take a
payment even when i make it rain i make
a statement let the rain fall on my
enemies
fall on my enemies let the rain fall on
my enemies
all of my enemies
on all
[Music]
did it with no chains on i'll give you
the keys to no stress first you give god
the praise and see him work
i can't never be on my knees i'm too
blessed cause any time i make it rain or
reimburse then i let the rain fall on my
[Music]
enemies
my enemies on my face
[Music]
oh london our beautiful city has been
through the ringer
now it's fallen into the hands of
criminal organizations vying to control
whatever's left
it's all gone to [__] lucky for us our
underground hacker collective dedsec
is here to build a resistance
but where do we start look around
hipsters
punks football fans construction workers
paramedics
annoying tourists grandparents what do
they all have in common
any one of them could become your next
playable hero
[Music]
and help you save the city
[Applause]
let's do some recruiting shall we well
this one looks promising let's hack into
his profile
ah dan a getaway driver he has a
completely custom vehicle to make for a
fast exit
and an anti-chase ability making him
immune to those pesky chase drones
he can also hack vehicles to clear the
way they'll come in handy and hop the
suit
or let's see him in action
[Music]
or how about eleanor a hacker could
always be useful
thanks to her viral hacking skill car
hacks propagate
affecting everything in the surrounding
area she also can electrify enemies with
a shock hack
and can steal access keys without
needing to enter an enemy location
epic feeling a little more artsy in your
approach
teresa is a street artist her paintball
gun gives her a non-lethal way to take
out enemies
and she has paint bombs that can
disorient them
[Music]
not bad eh so how do you convince the
people of london to join your team
talk to them and find out what it takes
to prove that your cause is worthy
tell me what's wrong i witnessed albion
doing some peak [__] these clan kelly
guys
they've gone too bloody far my friend's
gone missing don't worry that's
it we'll find them after you help them
they will join your ranks and become the
stars of your story
[Music]
[Applause]
as you explore london keep a lookout
some of the most
legendary recruits are not someone you
just run into every day
like this robotic beekeeper shelby she
can wreak havoc
using her be swarm she also has a unique
weapon
the overcharger her suit gives her shock
immunity
so she can take more damage from certain
attacks
[Music]
you can recruit the old bloody city if
you want doesn't mean you should
henry here's got low mobility so he's
not really fit for a mission that
requires you to be
nimble and mark
is a hitman seems like the perfect
recruit
but if you're approaching a stealth
mission
maybe you should keep an eye out for
another hitman whose attributes don't
include hiccups no matter who you
recruit you can specialize each
individual to complement your playstyle
by choosing one of the many unlockable
weapons and gadgets like the missile
truck
the ar cloak the spider butts
yes i did say spider butt
this is your team make it the way you
like recruit skillful people
adapting for various types of missions
or go with weirdos and grannies
no one's here to judge so get out in the
streets
and assemble your dream team
[Applause]
london is calling
hello everyone my name is leticia
inaudin i am the live producer on
watchdog's legion on behalf of the
entire dev team
i want to send a huge thank you to all
the fans for the love
and support since our announcement and
today i'm happy to announce
that an old friend is coming back
a fight back easy to say
hard to do maybe
i'm just what the city needs
are you ready for me london
you asked and he's back older but not
necessarily wiser
aiden pierce will be a fully playable
character in washaw's legion
as part of our post-launch plans check
them out
and that's not all we're going to open
up a whole new chapter
in a story as part of our standalone dlc
included
in our season pass
stay tuned and welcome to the resistance
everyone has a good reason to join the
resistance in watchdogs legion
the fight for freedom begins on october
29th
ubisoft forward will be back in the
upcoming months with more of everything
you want to know about our developing
games
but before we go here's one more thing
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
um
[Music]
my name is charlotte i work in ubisoft
nsc and i'm a senior community developer
today i'm very excited to announce our
new iep raiders republic
writers republic is a mass multiplayer
game
where you enjoy extreme sports outdoors
together with your friends and the
community
our studio is known for its expertise on
many multiplayer games
and there is a huge word to explore so
i'm very excited
writer's republic for me is about just
killing it on dream terrain with the
sickest extreme sports and doing it with
other people
for writer's republic you enter into
this world with all these people around
you
which gives you a ton of possibilities
to group up with them to challenge them
to experiment with different extreme
sports on different types of terrain
you have forest you have snow you have
sand you have mountains you have cliffs
it's amazing when you see all these
people just flying around you
jumping off of jumps jumping through
gates it's just it's one of those
visions that you're like oh my god this
game is crazy
this game is that next-gen social
interaction game
with a huge world and a lot of
possibilities
it's literally an extreme sports fantasy
land
our objective was to really depict
natural places and we wanted to go for
the biggest the most impressive natural
places in the world so we decided to go
to the u.s
national parks what we did is actually
stitching
together seven regions in a way that
feels natural
but for each of them we actually used
gps data
so that everything you see stand there
for real
and i think it's gonna be a great
experience our philosophy was to be able
to welcome different kinds of player
let them enjoy the game the way they
want choose their setting choose their
sport
and let them go where they want to go
we're very excited to be able to reveal
it to the world
so now i've got one more thing for you
to check out enjoy it
all right they just dropped the trailer
my moment of glory awaits god damn it
how do you work this piece of junk
they don't build them like they used to
welcome to writer's republic adrenaline
junkies there are no
rules here but what's a republic without
a constitution am i
right here's a few truths about how we
lay it down
we the writers welcome all thrill
seekers to the republic
[Music]
proponents of madness get ready for
radness
we the writers salute the rationality of
irrationality
we the writers say that friends who slay
together
stay together gather your best friends
go crazy baby
[Music]
if you ride the republic will abide
go rogue or go home
[Music]
we the riders insist that you do you
always
outrace out trick out perform
and gain some cred by sharing the magic
with the rest of the republic
we the riders claim the right to bear
the best gear
boards planks bikes or wings whatever
bakes your cake
[Music]
be it road freestyle slope style and
girl
or downhill as you grow the trip gets
so slick and it'll help you drop bigger
clips
[Applause]
we the riders assure epic events to
build your rep welcome to x games
it's time to make some history signed
with hot sponsors and qualify for big
time competitions
make a name for yourself we never stop
doing things
for the first time red bull rampage the
harshest and most unforgiving canvas for
big mountain
riders
i can't even begin to express how
technical that was
these are the gnarliest jumps i've ever
seen in one room
we the riders invite you to leave the
roads and take the trails
explore the land climb the peaks roam
the natural world
after all bad manners to keep the
mountains waiting
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
guarantee a ton of insane contests all
the time
there's trick battles to grind your way
through somebody
and join community challenges
yeah reach that finish line first
join us because we are the republicans
be on the lookout for more updates on
writer's republic
in the coming months
[Music]
today you got the first in-depth look at
immortals phoenix rising
caught a glimpse of prince of persia
sansa time remake
got to fight off seven evil exes in scot
program versus the world the game
and witnessed the big reveal of writer's
republic
along with so much more
you can expect more reveals and news in
the next ubisoft forward
be sure to stay tuned for the post show
featuring a walkthrough of immortals
phoenix rising
and a roller champions show match
hello everybody and welcome to the
ubisoft forward post
show i'm mimi community developer on
immortals feelings
rising we know you've got a lot of
questions for us
so reach out on social channels and i'm
gonna tell you about it
in a moment but first
let's jump into the game in an area
dedicated to the god of blacksmiths
metalwork and invention this is the land
of estos
hello everyone my name is scott phillips
game director
on immortals phoenix rising today i'm
incredibly excited to show you a sneak
peek of our unique game
immortals phoenix rising is an open
world action-adventure game with a fresh
stylized look and feel heavily inspired
by greek mythology
it's a tale of the gods told by the gods
themselves
on this epic journey you'll play as
phoenix fully customizable greek warrior
according to prophecy phoenix is the
only one who can save the greek gods
from typhon
the deadliest titan of them all
to do this phoenix will explore the
golden isle a mysterious mythical island
dedicated to the gods today we join her
as she arrives in hephaestus
region to reignite his legendary forge
to gain his assistance in the upcoming
battle against typhon
[Music]
two paths to re-lighting the forge of
hephaestus lie before us
we could challenge aminotar and his
friends to unblock the air vents
or reignite the hearths of the forge
both will lead us to face a legendary
automaton
let's go to the forge
before we start our adventure we'll use
farsight to scout the journey ahead
this rift seems interesting let's make
our way there
during her journey phoenix will reclaim
legendary pieces of equipment
such as the wings of daedalus seen here
these wings allow phoenix to soar
through the air
your flying companion phosphorus will
join phoenix on her adventures as well
more on that later
here's a nice opportunity to gather some
ingredients we'll use them for potions
later
in immortals phoenix rising combat is an
acrobatic airborne
over-the-top mythological experience
with her powers
phoenix can dominate these soldiers
but this cyclops is another story
boulders are his weapon of choice
phoenix wields three legendary weapons
but her ultimate weapons are her godly
abilities
that move was athena's dash
[Music]
ouch that's gotta hurt
smashing the ground is also one of his
favorite attacks
let's take a health potion just to be
safe
another chain of ability attacks and
he's knocked out
stunning enemies provides an opportunity
to get in a lot of hits to regenerate
stamina
now we'll finish the fight with
hephaestus hammer
boom when enemies are defeated they shed
adamantium
used to upgrade phoenix's gear now that
the fight is done
we can make our way towards the rift
rifts are tears in the veil to the
underworld of tartarus
typhon's realm
vaults of tartarus challenge your wit
logic and dexterity
and are also a place to combine your
abilities and combat skills
solve puzzles and navigate your
surroundings
across dozens of vaults will face a huge
variety of challenges
where you'll need to mix and match your
weapons and skills to overcome them
waiting at the end of each vault is a
lightning bolt of zeus
using their legendary power phoenix can
upgrade her stamina
[Music]
hidden chests lie in each vault uncover
them to seal the rift
on the golden isle typhon's army lurks
around every corner
and as we all know where there are
enemies there's loot
gliding with the wings of daedalus is
always a joy
but we need to keep an eye on how much
stamina we're using
since flying harpies can be a challenge
to reach we can use the bracers of
heracles to pull ourselves toward them
to start the fight
oops phoenix needs to be careful with
their stamina here potion will do the
trick
[Music]
and now on to the next one
like the cyclops minotaurs also love to
use the environment to attack phoenix
but with heracles bracers we can grab
them and throw them right back
he'll also try to hit you with those
nasty horns or slash you with his claws
perfect dodges will grant phoenix some
precious extra time
[Music]
ouch the minotaur's charge can hit
pretty hard fortunately
phoenix has some health potions
with a few more perfect dodges phoenix
will land some quick attacks
but let's finish this fight with the
help of our companion phosphorus
to dive bomb the minotaur
[Music]
let's see what they were guarding the
golden isle is filled with epic scale
puzzles
inspired by greek mythology each trial
will require you to discover
understand and then solve the challenge
these trials are found scattered across
the entire world just waiting to be
found
when completed you'll learn coins of
charon to be used in upgrading phoenix's
skills and abilities
now that we've put our wits to the test
let's move on to the next part of our
quest
the first step to re-lighting the forge
is to destroy some of the corruption
that typhon has spread over the golden
island
[Music]
with the corruption destroyed we can use
heracles strength to grab some coal
and put it in the hearth to start the
fire
this is just one of many ways to light
the coal on fire
[Music]
the hearth is now relent but since a
battle with a legendary automaton awaits
us at the forge
let's head to our base of operations for
some upgrades
[Music]
this is the hall of the gods it is where
phoenix will reunite the gods to defeat
typhon
all of phoenix's progression and
customization takes place in this
central hub
at the river stick cistern we'll spend
coins of charon to upgrade hephaestus
hammer ability
perfect for the fight to come
[Music]
on her journey to defeat typhon phoenix
will need all of the upgrades she can
[Music]
get
with our new ability restocked potions
and increased health and stamina
we're ready for this final fight
built by hephaestus but corrupted by
typhon this automaton can unleash lasers
on phoenix
[Music]
to start things off right let's use an
attack potion to enhance phoenix's
weapons and abilities
preparing her for the rest of the fight
athena's dash
and aries wrath are all good choices
here
the automaton's uppercut is quite deadly
but this combo will knock him right at
it
[Music]
let's finish him off with our newly
acquired ability
and he's history
power has been restored to the forge
ifestos workshop is roaring back to life
phoenix's job is done
seems typhon has other plans we're
seeing typhon's rage
which means he sent a corrupted fallen
hero to track phoenix down
this walkthrough was just a preview of
the amazing journey phoenix will
experience
in immortals phoenix rising more trials
more larger-than-life monsters and more
adventures await you on the golden aisle
thank you for watching see you december
3rd
[Music]
and there it is now december turn may
seem like a long way off
but we've got a lot
hey everyone and welcome back to the
gamespot post show for ubisoft forward
september edition joining me once again
tomorrow hussein
hello i'm jordan remain
what's up all right so
we actually called quite a lot of that
which i'm kind of proud of us for
for reading twitter and seeing what late
but let's go through the showcase
um kind of one by one uh we'll go
through like immortals prince of persia
hyperscape siege some upsetting uses of
sam fisher
scott pilgrim watch legion and riders
republic
but first i want to get a kind of
test the waters from the two of you what
did you think of the show time i'll come
to you first
uh i thought it was fine nothing major
to surprise us
um i wanted a big reveal
of something um uh oh like a new game
and like the prince of persia stuff
maybe would have been it but i felt kind
of like um
i wanted to see more of how the gameplay
actually
is going to work in the new version they
kind of just showed off like visual
stuff and they showed that yuri's back
and
and a few other things and i'm excited
that the india team is getting a chance
to take a crack at it i think that was
alpha footage so
i expect improvements for it but nothing
in that
entire uh kind of press conference that
was like holy moly can't believe this is
happening
maybe one thing which we'll discuss
later but that's a very personal thing
nevertheless still a solid show um a lot
of interesting cool looking games coming
out
um aidan pierce is back
we'll talk about aim please in a second
jordan what about you what did you make
of it
i'm kind of in the exact same boat i
thought it was
fine i'm still just
amazed that ubisoft is planning to
release watchdogs legions assassins
creed valhalla
and immortals phoenix rising back to
back to back just
three months in a row that's a lot of
giant open world games to try to squeeze
in on the holiday
season i was convinced before
hearing about the release date for
immortals that it was going to be
postponed to early
2021 but i guess ubisoft just wants to
get in those big holiday bucks just at
the end of the year and just
slam three giant games at us all at the
same time i don't know when i'm gonna
have the time to play through
all of them but i'm going to try
well it's not just through the end of
the year it's the next five
months it's uh watchdogs in october
assassins in november
uh immortals in december then you've got
prince of persia in january and then
it's far cry in february
it's gonna be a busy a busy few months
but i'm excited
about a lot of titles let's talk about
immortals so i
like we talked about it in the pre-show
we're all kind of very into the concept
of what it is like
taking these greek gods and myths and
doing something really cool and
interesting with them kind of
a little bit that was touched on in the
more
fantastical aspects of assassin's creed
odyssey i would say
but i'm really into it i'm excited that
you get to you know make and customize
your own
phoenix um did you get that they're a
demigod
really hammer in that home but i think
is it coming on switch i know it's
coming on stadia uh
but jordan i'm gonna throw it to you
so i didn't hear anything about sweat
no i was gonna say because we did we we
did know that that was coming jordan
you've um seen a bunch of the game can
you talk about your experience with it
what's it like
so you might be able to
get some of this just watching the
game play but it seems
some of the mechanics and features are
just inspired by similar ideas that
went into breath of the wild it's very
much a game where you can
climb everything you're only limited by
how much stamina you have and you're
trying to get to
high places to scout ahead and find
landmarks that you think are cool and
then glide over to those places it's not
like the
typical ubisoft stuff where you're
climbing tower after after tower to like
add icons to your map you actually have
to go
discover the thing and a lot of the
things are these little
shrine tomb like things that you can go
inside complete puzzle or combat
challenges
to unlock more stamina and so
it's a very similar like core gameplay
loop to breath of the wild where your
own like curiosity kind of informs where
you go next and what you want to do
next which is really cool but at the
same time it's made by that
assassin's creed odyssey team so a lot
of the
combat mechanics and powers feel more
reminiscent of what we saw in
odyssey as opposed to lynx adventure and
breath of the wild so it's kind of like
this
almost mixture between the
two games and it's and it sometimes
works i i'm a little bit on the
fence about it i'm like it's hard to
tell how a game is going to be based on
a demo because they have to kind of
shove everything at you as quickly as
they can
within like an hour and a half two hours
so
my play style with it was very
linear like the demo s was kind of
telling me where to go next and like all
the icons were already on my map so
it'll be interesting to see
how much that curiosity in forming the
player's decision
actually pans out because i wasn't
really able to get that
in the demo i played but that's like my
favorite part of games like
breath of the wild and witcher and stuff
like that so if it works in immortals
then i've found another game that i'm
going to
love to play but that still just remains
to be seen until we get
more hands-on with it i mean that's the
thing really because
if you take the two very different
approaches to game design where
nintendo are very much especially within
breath of the wild it's let the player
explore and form their own adventure
whereas ubisoft are icons icons icons
handhold handheld handheld i will and
when you're taking
so much from a game like breath of the
wild i do wonder if like the core
innate ubisoftness will
you know they'll be able to let go a
little bit and just let the player
uh just explore by themselves but i'm
excited about this one time what about
you
yeah i'm you know the inspiration of the
legend of zelda breath of the wild
is only a good thing for a lot of games
the game is incredible um i'm really
intrigued by the humor like they
mentioned it as a specific thing
um they're kind of like focusing on and
i'm excited to see some more of that
they were like little character
like the humor could manifest in so many
different ways that i'm
really uh excited to check out it could
be in the writing which we've seen some
indication of like during the trailer
but like also the characterization you
had that
that character there with their big old
belly that was like really enjoying
rubbing it which was like kind of
endearing
um so i yeah i i'm and also that freedom
to kind of explore they've talked about
you know jordan's written a preview
about it which is available on hit video
game website gamespot.com
um and he talks about some of the kind
of um
mechanical stuff and the idea of a you
know a god
or a you know typhoon is kind of like
peeved that you're doing things and
we'll just send out
hunters after you and you can't always
defeat them but they have a big impact
on the world around you and
they design so you fear them and choose
to run away and that kind of stuff
um so it's it's called that kind of
elements and seeing what they do with
like immediately making everything open
to you instead of getting it by levels
um again like it could be an interesting
experiment for ub software if this works
for them
you know maybe if assassin's creed
starts to shift into something like this
or maybe
you know this this game spawns its own
new franchise that is close to the
traditional model that they're very
comfortable with making
and they seem to lean towards but has
enough new to it that it could be
treated as its own fresh new thing
it looks very cute um should we move on
they had
uh so straight from unless jordan
because you did actually preview it
anything
any kind of closing remarks you've got
uh only really the go off the cute
comment i love the fact that phosphorus
your bird actually flies alongside you
whenever you're gliding everywhere
they're just like this wonderful little
cute almost phoenix looking companion
that follows you around everywhere and i
love them so much
it's so cute i also like the name i also
shout out to the guy for saying is it
hecatonkari's which is maybe my new
favorite word
which is of the hundred islands uh
mythological beast
uh i did not expect to see that in a
press conference all right let's move on
prince of persia
remake uh leaked uh obviously
i'm i love sounds of time i'm
cautiously optimistic about this one i
tweeted out during the conference
actually that he reminded me the the new
looking
prince looks like the guy from the road
to el dorado and now
unfortunately that's all i'll be able to
see um
i i'm a little not concerned because you
still got a few months until january
but like still alpha
i would have expected something i guess
a little more cleaned up
uh for a big reveal like this on a stage
like a ubisoft forward but
there are still some months left to you
know ought to do a final pass to fix up
things that look a little bit
um a little bit alpha let's say uh
time what do you reckon yeah i i think
um there should have been like i think
it looks
like it's the thing that people who
really have the nostalgia for the game
will probably check
out i would was hoping it'd look a bit
more like
cleaned up and a little more like uh
visually interesting given that we're on
the cusp of new generation of consoles
it's going to be a bit of a jarring uh
kind of process to play this game going
from
you know new brand new games on new
consoles going back to this game which
looks like
it if i'm being honest like it looks
like an early ps4 game
if if late like a previous gen game
but like you said alpha um and
a lot can happen in in in the period
that it goes from alpha to final
um build of the game so i imagine it's
going to look better
the thing that they didn't show is what
i said earlier like is that is the
gameplay changed
in any way um have they made any
modernizations to make it a little more
interesting
to play a little more palatable for
modern game uh
players who have you know they're used
to a bunch of
um steps forward in design and
implementation
i'm like just watching that trailer back
again uh while
you know during the conference it's wild
to me how much of it really
sprang back like i remember those
specific traps i remember
the feeling of uh rewinding time jordan
you didn't play the
uh sansa time when it came out is this
got you is this piqued your interest
no i'm i'm sorry just just looking at it
i'm like i
i still don't really and maybe this is
just a failing on my part because i
never actually went back to see what
sands of time actually
was but i'm like i'm not really sure
what this game
is and like what you're supposed to
do and how you play it and whatnot and
i'm just looking i'm like
there's nothing here like springing out
to me that makes me
someone who's never played the original
now want to buy this one to
see what all the fuss was about i don't
know
yeah maybe a new trailer well like yeah
it's alpha like i said so relying on
people who've played it before like if i
didn't know the storyline i don't think
i could get it
across there like the fact that it's the
maharaja
at the at the beginning like he's kind
of the big bad how the sands of time
even
come into the storyline what your
relationship with far is even the fact
that pharah is an npc who follows you
around and you know helps you solve
puzzles
i don't think that was really put across
very well
um but hopefully they will kind of
address that later on but i'm
this is probably my biggest thing from
today like
the fact that they've got yuri lowenthal
back to kind of redo the voice
i like even just hearing the voice again
i was like oh man it's 2003
i'm at my friend katie's house and we're
playing this on her ps2
like i'm very excited about prince of
persia um
but let's move on hype escape let's not
dwell on this too long in fact i don't
even think i'm gonna throw to either of
you because
that was hype escape still exists um
yeah i mean i i it was nothing it was
nothing
yeah i mean i mean i get it it's a
service title you kind of have to and
it's
just launched you kind of want to remind
people that it's out there that it's
free to play
um but i think yeah
it didn't necessarily have a good spot
in the running order coming straight off
the back of a
beloved uh classic title being remade
but then uh rainbow six uh like we
talked about in the pre-show
uh sam fisher uh popped out a little
early
uh on psn and xbox earlier today um
but i think one of the big things is
that there's gonna be a rainbow six
world cup
next year summer next year and the
upgrade to next gen will be free and
it'll be
uh 4k 120 frames which uh
it must be exciting for people who play
that game i'm afraid that i don't have
i'm gonna throw it to you
if you're playing on pc it's you know
they're updating it it's going to look
better anyway
um the playstation 4 version is what
primarily i played on the console
um and that game is struggles on perhaps
it's just my ps4 but like i know that
like the loading times
the the they kind of like moving through
the ui is a bit itchy so that's what i'm
most excited about like being able to
navigate the menus and and do things
without it like feeling like it's a
struggle
but that game is really really still
impressive and
even and now like it's a beautiful game
the destruction stuff doesn't get old
and it still hasn't for me like
i'm not a i don't play as much as
perhaps other people
um like i'm i dip in and out just to
make sure that my
um kind of awareness around the game is
still there and i'll
i'll have like months long stretches
where i get really into it and
the destructibility part of it is super
super cool still
um and being able seeing them like uh
take that and leverage it with more
visual kind of bells and whistles is
amazing but fundamentally i think the
most exciting part of this is having a
game as
intricate and as exciting as rainbow six
siege available
immediately or like soon after you get
new consoles and
a community already being there and a
developer that's clearly committed to
you know exploring the future of that
game and guaranteeing it is super
exciting
yeah and the fact that it's gonna be a
free upgrade to can't ready sniff at
that one
uh let's move on then so scott pilgrim
i'm like i said in the pre-show maybe
this is the time that i'll actually be
able to complete that game
but it felt like this music and see the
visuals and stuff
jordan are you excited about this one i
actually i did like the trailer and this
was another one of those
ubisoft games that just kind of passed
me by and i didn't play and i'm like
okay yeah i i can see why people like
this the music is pretty dope and the
combat seems to be at least decent from
what i can tell
i'll pick it up i'll try it i don't know
how far i'll get into it i remember
playing river city girls and eventually
just hitting a roadblock that i couldn't
overcome and this is like the same basic
game but
i'll try my best to play it on my own
maybe i'll ask ben or
john luke to help me in co-op
i was gonna say it's a very it's like i
played by myself which is probably why
i'd never beat it but like
playing in cops definitely seems like
the way to go and also it's just like
it can really run with all of the um
sort of pop culture
uh references from the comic and from
the movies and it's just visually i just
love what they've done with it time are
we are we going to play
yes we're going to play um i hope i hope
that
my my greatest office like before in the
pre-show i said like
i'm not sure how many people will
actually commit to buying this and
replaying it uh
i don't i don't know if i believe it's
as many as have cried out for it
but um i hope that a lot of people do
buy it because this is a genre that is
starting to kind of pick up steam again
and i would love to see it come back in
a big bad way we had a new streets of
rage which was really cool
um and this coming back this is one of
the popular modern kind of like so i've
scrolling beat him up games
um so i'd love to see people pick it up
and
kind of like ask for more and and for
the appetite around it to become obvious
and developers like ubisoft and others
you know think about making more um but
yeah we should play
and enjoy some music and smash some
other buttons
i think you can say smash some guinea
pigs
absolutely oh mama
that's why that's why i generally
thought i was gonna go there but
apparently not
i i forget over the fact that it's 10
years old
i feel like that has gone by upsettingly
quickly
um but also let's talk a little bit
about watch dogs legion
um so i mean straight off the bat
getting stormzy in to do music for the
game is a fantastic choice
um and the fact that he has his own
music video within the game
and his own uh ra fall on my enemies
mission which
uh i'm definitely gonna do i hope that's
just a part of the game and not part of
like
a season pass because i think more
people definitely just need to be
exposed
to stormzy um he's very much someone who
like he just embodies london i think and
i'm very excited to
see him get the platform within the game
uh time you're a big fan
yep stormzy is obviously i am from
east london grime is one of my preferred
music genres stormzy
is a huge deal um his album gang signs
and prayers is
one of my favorite albums of all time
this song is called rainfall it's of his
latest album and it's
amazing um so and like stormzy is great
because one he's
also an advocate for a lot of the issues
within
the black community and london in
general he's done a lot to
for the community there and opened up
schools and that kind of stuff and
a big voice within in like social
justice as well so
not only a talented artist but also a
good dude for the for the most part
um so having him in this game is like a
level of authenticity that speaks to
modern day londoners i really like um
the users
will certainly check out what's going on
with um watchdogs
legion now that one of like the premier
graham artists
um out there is is kind of like in it
and so
very shrewd and smart business move from
ubisoft and
another great opportunity for stormzy uh
you should everyone should listen to
um gang signs and prayers and his new
album heavy instagram
yeah it was strange because obviously
like being more on american
on an american time zone i saw a lot of
people in my twitter feed being like i
don't know who storms he is but he seems
cool i'm like
yeah yeah this is gonna be a very good
this is it um so jordan when
we were actually watching the press
conference uh you said i feel like i've
seen this trailer
before and it's very much inclined
it's one of those things that watch dogs
like every
trailer i think that we've gotten for
legion or at least the vast majority of
them are like you can play as anyone let
us give you an example
of two to four people that you can play
as and i'm like
i get it i get the fact that i can play
as anyone and that some of these people
are
really weird choices to choose for
a hacker group or something like that
can you
show me some more of like the missions
and
how like the story works with your
characters kind of just like
intersperse and interchanging between
each cutscene and whatnot like
i i don't know maybe maybe ubisoft just
knows that
everyone who enjoyed watch dogs 2 is
probably already on board to buy watch
dogs legions and they're
prepared to just accept those numbers
but i
i want something else besides the fact
that
you can play as anyone in watchdog's
legion because that seems to be like the
game's only
selling point at this point in time and
maybe that's all it needs but i
feel like with the open rpg genre like
so
saturated with so many different titles
you need to show a little bit more about
how you can differentiate yourself from
the crowd
especially if you're the first of three
giant open world ubisoft games that are
coming out this year
yeah i mean i totally get it like it's
very much
it reminds me of um back when they first
launched a middle earth shadow of mordor
and the only thing they were talking
about was the nemesis system
uh like every single beat was the
nemesis system because it was so new
and i feel like there's kind of elements
of that in this because it is such a
grand
system like it's such a huge claim being
able to say you can play as literally
anyone in our game
and luckily for us we can play as
ayden pierce
[Music]
so when honestly when said like
someone is returning i thought
for some reason in my head like aisha
tyler was in the first watch dogs and
you couldn't play as her obviously but
she was in the game
as an npc or you know someone from watch
dogs too
like they had that casted core cast of
characters a really cool main character
and like i thought it'd be water sharks
too because it's a little more hip and
kind of more in line with how i feel
that watchdog's legion is going where
it's
um you know less sad dad energy that
aiden pierce brings
but apparently people love him and he's
he's coming back
um tam what do you think
well they opened with you asked for him
and i was like who who who asked her
who's asking
yeah i was like great they're gonna put
sam in another game great
and we won't get another splinter cell
um but like
okay whatever like if you want to put
him in there sure like
that he's like optional he's probably
going to be dlc so
fair enough and in a game where you yeah
and and
in a game where you can literally play
as anyone like you play it in pierce for
a minute and you're like okay cool
people who really love him for some
reason and his baseball cap can stick
with him great
but obviously this is not a game about
that and it also kind of speaks to
why it's so tricky to show off new
content like
systems are very difficult to
like to truly show off how one thing you
know the domino effect of doing one
thing
and how it impacts you in the moment 10
minutes later an hour later and
and hours and hours later over the
course of the game is really tricky to
show off in short
sharp demonstrations um but this is a
game about options and
if you don't care about aiden pierce
which i absolutely do not care about
aiden pierce like this was
this was watchdogs for me is remembered
as the game that like like assassin's
creed one they took a first attempt at
and didn't quite hit
and for me the thing that stuck out
really was like it was devoid of
personality
and like any interesting characters and
they started to make
real good strides to fixing that with
watch folks too with marcus and
san francisco being a more vibrant
interesting place so
as jordan mentioned and various other
people mentioned before like
why you'd pick aidan over marcus is wild
but obviously aiden is the poster boy
for the franchise uh which is a
franchise that otherwise doesn't have
any other distinguishing features in
amongst
uh or a slate of open world ubisoft
games there's no one in
like you can pull out a new assassin's
creed game and very
like um reliably present a character and
be like people will immediately know
who this is because one they've got the
the hood or like some element of
assassin's creed iconography that makes
sense for watch dogs they don't have
that
they don't have like an obvious thing
the closest they have is the baseball
cap so get the dude attached to the
baseball cap
yeah i mean as well i think it's easy to
say in hindsight
like oh maybe aiden peace wasn't the
best but like
watchdogs when it first came out so like
broke records for ubisoft it was the
highest selling uh new ip for them
uh for a long time and you kind of can't
ignore that and i'm sure
and i think maybe it's just a numbers
game and that like so many people played
that game
probably not because of aiden pierce but
so many people did
um all right finally they revealed a
brand new title from
ubisoft anisee so they're probably best
known as the steep
studio um the kind of
extreme snow sports game from a few
years ago
but now they're taking that concept and
they're basically putting it in
x games mode uh with what's it called
riders republic
um i
like i appreciate that this game is not
for me it has
cool ideas but um it's not one for me
but i like the fact that it has way more
personality it kind of
reminds me a little bit more of trials i
did think it would be trials actually at
the
very beginning but i
yeah it looks cute it's just it's just
not one for me i don't think uh
either of you can play it time yeah it's
got like i i'm
excited to check it out steep was like
when when
steve was first announced and we were
previewing it we were like oh is this
gonna fill the void that ssx has left
and
ultimately it really didn't like sleep
got better over time and
it's an interesting game to check out
but it didn't fill the ssx void mainly
because the void
that i want to be filled is ssx tricky
um that is my favorite ssx game and this
is coming close to it it has got
some size style to it it's got some
personality it's a little more bombastic
and audacious
and it's got like a like a motor storm
vibe to me
it's like that franchise has obviously
gone rip to that studio um
like that so the fact that ubisoft is
kind of stepping in and
this is clearly a a gap in the market
that they want to take hold of otherwise
they wouldn't
keep putting out these extreme sports
games
in a way that no one else really does um
and it looks like there's more to this i
like the idea of giving people like
gameplay variety
and and letting people mix it up it
seems like they're taking bits of what
made the crew great in terms of the
variety stuff and
injecting a little more personality and
we'll see how it comes together but i'm
more interested in this than i
am with the crew or steep
jordan what do you make of it i mean
extreme sports games aren't
really my jam so i feel like this is
kind of the
market that i kind of just watch from a
distance i'm like oh it's doing very
well and people seem to really like it
but i almost never
participate in it just watching the
trailer i'm was watching them like okay
cool cool cool cool cool cool and then
they showed the
first person perspective on like the
mountain bike portion and my anxiety
just like
shot through the roof so i'm sure that's
like just an
optional thing to like trigger on and
off but just solely based on that i'm
like i i can't go near this game
i just i won't be able to play it
no i i'm honestly um i've spoken at
length before about games that have made
me
feel motion sick and unfortunately
in a stuffy gamescom demo room
a few years ago i first played steep and
they there was the trailer it wasn't
even me playing the game it was part of
the trailer it was in first person
and i think they did a flip and i just
went i'm done i'm out
so again the first person rode
definitely not for me
but if it if it does manage to kind of
scratch that ssx tricky itch then
i can see myself like trying it but like
extreme sports not my thing i'm you know
i don't go outside so
like
i dabbled with skateboarding which is
and like
my friends they bought him so that's why
i really like tony hawk is because i was
like
on the very very fringe of that culture
for a while and like
you can just immerse yourself in that
whereas i have no experience with like
extreme sports other than that
it's like it's why i don't play driving
games or sports games they're just not
things that interest me
uh time you're gonna say something yeah
i was gonna say like
i think the thing that you are
interested in now and like a lot of
people will be in the same way is like i
think
there's been a bit of a like critical
mass of people finding games to play
that
just provide a communal experience with
friends maybe it's because of covid or
whatever it may be but like
i think i feel like more people are
inclined to try a game out just because
it presents them the opportunity to be
in a space with their friends
so people like you or even people like
me more recently like on on
super that might not be into the idea of
like a traditional sports game
you stick a oh you're based multiplayer
and you can hang out with your friends
and you can all like
start at the top of this mountain and
just bomb down it
um in in different vehicles and chat
away and have fun
that seems appealing so i wonder how
much or i hope that they kind of play
that up and show
how the game works with those people
that kind of game play style in mind
because that would be something that is
more appealing to me
definitely um if it's just like oh you
can do tricks and you have this extreme
sports experience
okay maybe i'm interested but if it's
like oh you can group up with a bunch of
friends and you can do these wild
challenges together and
it relies on you needing to each of you
needing to do x y and z so you you know
you know get these high scores then i'm
like okay i can maybe convince my friend
circle or that i play games with
regularly to get into it
yeah i think that's a that's a really
good point i didn't really consider um
because a lot of the times on the
weekend a bunch of us just get together
and play games but at the end of the day
sometimes it's not even about playing
those games at all it's just about
hanging out with your friends so if this
is a good
vehicle to do that then i'll give it a
try especially if you get some really
wacky
uh like bail compilations out of it
um all right everyone thank you so much
for joining us for our ubisoft forward
post show i'm pretty sure if you've been
around the whole time
uh there is going to be another ubisoft
forward coming very soon uh
so make sure to check back youtube.com
gamespotgamesupply.com
for all the latest on ubisoft games as
well as deep dives jordan's preview of
immortals um
as well as an interview with the team
behind prince of persia
remake thanks for watching we'll see you
next time
[Music]
so
you